مشاهدينا ننتقل الى نقل وقائع كلمه للرئيس
الاوكراني فولدمير ريزولنسكي هذه الكلمه
التي تاتي اليوم بمناسبه مرور عام على
الغاز الروسي لاوكرانيا
خلال هذه السنه
فاننيون
اود ان اشكر الصحفيين الاوكرانيين وكذلك
اود ان تقدم بالشكر لكم جميعا اشكركم على
كل ما قدمتموه لبلدنا
وبالافال فانتم الى جانبنا والى جانب كل
الشعب الاوكراني وكذلك الجيش وانتم ايضا
الممثلين عن وسائل الاعلام وكذلك اصدقائنا
وشركائنا اود ان اشكركم جميعا
وانكم قد بدلتم الكثير بغيه الانتصارنا
وكل هذا الامر
يسمح لي بان اشكركم شكرا جزيلا ان العالم
برمته يعرف اليوم اوكرانيا
وكذلك العالم لا ينسى انكرانيا وهذا
يساعدنا على ان نقهر ابدا
كانت هذه الاشهر صعيبه جدا وكذلك السنه
صعبه للغايه لكننا لم نقهر واود ان اشكركم
جميعا اشكرك ان اود ان اشكر زملائكم الذين
لم يعودوا معنا اليوم
والذين لن يكونوا معنا ابدا فلقد ضحوا
بحياتهم من اجل الانتصار الانتصار
اوكرانيا
وهم اشخاص ايضا كانوا صحفيين
وبالتالي علينا ان
نقف
لذاكرتها هؤلاء الصحفيين
دقيقه صمت لو سمحتم
انه من الاهميه بمكان بالنسبه لنا هذا
الامر كذلك بالنسبه لهم
بالتالي يمكننا الان ان نبدا هذا هذا
الاجتماع ومن المهم ان
تدلوا عن
اسمكم الكلمه
يتحدثون ويقولون مهما تطلب الامر ذلك
وبالتالي لماذا تعتقدون ان هذا ممكن في
نهايه هذه السنه وما معنى كلما تطلب الامر
ذلك من وجهه نظر اوكرانيا
مهمه جدا جدا
فنحن
بانتصارنا وكذلك شركائنا ستكون هناك
انتصار للقيم لو فعلنا ذلك على النحو
السليم الامر لا يتعلق بكلام فارغ فقط
اعتقد باننا اقوياء وشركائنا اقوياء
وعلينا ان نطلع بواء جيباتنا فقط
فانني اعتقد باننا جميعا عندما سنتطرق
نطلع بمهامنا
فاننا سنصل الى النصر على يقين بالنسبه
لذلك لان لدينا كلما نحن بح اليه فنحن
لدينا المواطنين وانتم موحدون موحدون ضد
هذا الغزو واعتقد بانه ليس هناك من بلد في
العالم الذي سيكون على حده ويبقى منعزل
امام هذا العدو
فان
نعتقد
ان اوكرانيا ليست وحدها كما قلت اوكرانيا
لها اصدقاء لها شركاء
وعلينا ان نسمح لهذا العدوان بان ينتشر
فان
يريد كل شيء اراد
القمه لكن نحن
نعتبر باننا بحاجه الى ان نعمل وان نعمل
يدا في يد وانا ذاك سننتصر بالتاكيد لان
الحقيقه هي الى جانبنا وكذلك الاطفال
الاطفال الذين نحبهم
والذين نضيعهم اليوم
وكما
تعلمون فانهم
يقصفون ويرمون قنابلهم
الذي تعطونه فاننا جميعا نؤمننا في الناصر
لكن سمعنا الى الكثير من الخبراء الاجانب
الذين قالوا بان هذه الحرب
اصبحت حرب
لكننا نريد نحن بحاجه يقول اننا بحاجه الى
ان نتفاوض ما هو الامر بالنسبه لكم
لا اعرف كيف سيحصل ذلك من الناحيه النظريه
نحن نقوم بخطوات ملموسه فاوكرانيا
تعمل من اجل السلام
ونحن فعلنا ذلك على مستوى مجموعه العشرين
نريد
نحن
قد ابرزنا على ما فعلته روسيا وان هذا
يؤثر على امننا وسلاماتنا
والازمه التي نعيشها من جرائم هذا الغوز
والروسي فلقد هاجموا مراكز نوويه وكذلك
منشات
اخرى
والسلاسل الاغذيه فانتم تعلمون ذلك هذا
فلقد
بخطوات واليوم لاحدنا
بان هناك
دعم لنا واود ان اقول بان يوم امس
في الامم المتحده الكثير من البلدان التي
دعمت مبادرتنا
ونتمنى بان يكون هناك اكبر عدد ممكن من
الدول التي
ستؤيدنا وان يكون هناك مؤتمر قمه واننا
سنبدو القصاره الجهود بغيه ان ينعقد هذه
القمه الكثير من البلدان في العالم ستشارك
في هذه القمه
ليست فقط
البلدان
من الشركاء التي
تشاب لكن بلدان اخرى
ممثلين عن الدول من مختلف القارات
واننا
سنتخذ كل الخطوات اللازمه حتى يكون هناك
ممثلون عن البلدان الافريقيه ووجودهم في
هذه الاقمه اتمنى ان يكون موجود وكذلك
الهند
ومهمتنا هو ان نجلب هذه البلدان قدر
الامكان نود ان نرى الشعوب وهي تتفق مع
ميثاق الامم المتحده وحقوق البشر للعيش
وان نرى ان تكون لدينا شهاده على الدعم
المقدم لنا هذه خطوات ديمقراطيه كلما
نفعله يتسم بالديمقراطيه الامور بسيطه
لانه هناك من الجيد ان نحظى بدعم من
البلدان مختلفه ال بلدان
بطبيعه الحال هذا شيء جيد هناك الكثير من
الاشياء التي
يمكننا ان نوفر تفاصيل بشانها
وفي نحن نريد السلام بطبيعه الحال نريد ان
تكون هناك ضمانه بالنسبه للامن والسلمي
عندما
سنحصل على هذا الضمان هذا سيكون جيد
فهذه الحرب تمس العالم برمته
ونحن
لدينا او نحن بالاحرى سنحترم البلدان
عندما تتخذ هذه الخطوات
فنحن نرغب
بارساء
الديمقراطيه لكن لابد وان نستجيب للكثير
من المتطلبات
التليفزيون المكسيكي
الكثير من الدول التي سولت لصالحك ماذا
تقولون للبلدان التي لم تدعم القرار
القرار الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
فهمي ما هو العالم
وما هي وهو الضياع
ونحن لا نضيع فقط الاراضي لكن ايضا نضيع
المواطنين والسكان عندما لا تعيشون الحرب
ولا تعرفون ما معنى الحرب فربما لا تفهمون
الامور
وهي الالام
ويكون ولهذا سبب فنحن نعمل معكم كل يوم
وفي كل الوقت لتهمي الحرب لان هذا يؤدي
الى
اللام
هولي
فنحن نريد ان نشرح ما معنى الحرب وما هي
الخسارات والضياع وكذلك التعذيب
وهل نحن بحاجه الى كل ذلك بالتالي
هذا يجعلنا نفهم ما يجري خلال الحرب
قياده الاتحاد الروسي
هل هي القياده بحاجه الى ذلك الامور معقده
من
الصعب جعل الاشخاص يفهمون لكن نحن
نفعل ذلك هناك
141 من البلدان التي
[موسيقى]
صوتت
القناه وسلامه
لقد فهمت هذه البلدان بان روسيا يجب ان
تنسحب من اراضينا
وانا اعتقد بان اوكرانيا عليها ان تسير
قدما الى الامام لتتصل بالقاره البلدان من
القاره الافريقيه نحن
نركز على هذه البلدان في الماضي ولهداف
فان اوكرانيا
فكرت في برنامج خاص يجب ان نكون متواجدين
ايضا في اسيا
وايضا حتى تكون هناك مبادرات ما علينا ان
نفعله هو علينا ان نقوم باستثمارات كل يوم
بغيه السلام لكننا اضعنا بعض الوقت ونحن
حتى اليوم نكافح من اجل استقلالنا
لم يكن لدينا قياده في اوكرانيا قبل الحرب
لكن اصبحنا اليوم اقوى ونحظى بدعم اقوى
لكن لا زالت هناك بعض الاشياء التي تنقصنا
انا اتحدث عن
البلدان من امريكا اللاتينيه وكذلك
افريقيا وهذا دعم مهم جدا
وانا امل بان يكون هناك قمه تشارك فيها
بلدان امريكا اللاتينيه وكذلك افريقيا
وانني ساذهب لهذه القمه هذا شيء مهم جدا
فانني لا اخشى الذهاب هناك ان
الدبلوماسيين على استعداد للعمل على مدارئ
الساعه
ويجب
[موسيقى]
نعمل والحرب تحثنا على ان نحذو هذا الحدوى
لم يكن احد يتوقع هذا ما فعلته روسيا
البلد الاجار
فلقد حاولوا تدميرنا كليا ولهذا
فنحن
نريد ان
بالافاعي
ان نعمل على هذه الطريقه واتطلع الى
المستقبل نحن بحاجه الى كل انحاء واطراف
العالم ونحن نعمل على هذا الاساس وهذا
الحوار وحوار نزيه ما بين البلدان
نريد ان نوحد البلدان الاوروبيه ليس فحسب
الاتحادي الاوروبي لكن بلدان اخرى كما قلت
هناك بعض البلدان المحايده ونحن نحث هذه
البلدان على ان تتخلى عن هذا
لا
يمكن ان
نتخلى عن ذلك وقت الحرب
فنحن على يقين باننا سننتصر بعد هذه
المعارك
فان
نحن بحاجه الى ان نفلح وننتصر هذه هي
الطريقه الوحيده التي يمكننا ان نتصرف بها
بغيه الوصول الى الناصر
بالكثير
ولكن حتى الان لم تتوصلوا بهذه المساعدات
لانها كانت بطيئه ولم تكن على المساواه
المتوقع
اليوم
تحثون على ان تكون هناك
جهود اضافيه
فان هذا سيختم مساحه بلدكم وان يحصل ذلك
في اقرب وقت
وذلك
لان هناك مسائله
ادبيه ثبت بهذا الامر هل
هناك الياتي المسائله بالنسبه
لجرائم الحرب
فهي تخص اوكرانيا والاوكرانيين
وكذلك
فان البلدان التي تؤيدكم الى
وجدت انفسها في نفس الوضع ووضعكم مثلا
تطلب اقل مما تطلبونه انتم
وشكرا لكم
ربما من الصعب ان اجيب على هذا سؤال
وتعقيبات لان هذا السؤال عميق للغايه
بالفعل هذا الامر مهمه بالنسبه
للانصاف فنحن
في هذه الامه فيما يتعلق بالمحكمه هذا شيء
مهم جدا فالامر يتعلق بالوحده السياسيه
وكذلك بالدعم فهذه دعم يجب ان يكون عالميا
ولكن هذه المنصه غير متوفره حتى الان حتى
تتوحد الابلدان من الناحيه السياسيه وهذه
المنصه ستسمح بانشاء
المحكمه
بالنسبه
للجرائم التي ارتكبها الاتحاد الروسي ونحن
نعمل على اساس ان تكون هناك اليات خاصه
بالنسبه
للخصارات التي لحقت بنا من جراء الغزو
الروسي
فنحن نعمل على هذا الاساس فكل
الدبلوماسيين وكذلك كل المدعين والوكلاء
يعملون كل يوم هذه اليه معقده للغايه
في الواقع
جل البلدان هي
من انشاء هذه المحكمه وتفهمون لماذا ذلك
فهذه مسؤوليه كبيره لكن لو انه
لا بد من السياسيه
للتوحيد
البلدان المتحده هي مفيده لهذا الغرض
كل بلد واي حكومه هو اي قاده الذين يحضرون
بالدعم في هذه العمليه يمكنهم ان يفلحوا
اتجاه هذا
الحل وبالتالي
نحن بحاجه الى خبراء
ونحن بحاجه الى البلدان
التي
تسمح
لنا بالوصول الى
انشاء هذه المحكمه هناك هولندا وكذلك هناك
الدول الاخرى نعمل معها على اساس اذا جبر
الضرر وكذلك هناك
الولايات المتحده هناك فلاندا وهناك
الكثير من يدعموننا بالفعل لكن الى جانب
ذلك
فنحن نعمل على اساس هذا الموضوع لماذا
الامور معقده الى هذه الدرجه
اعتقد بان المؤسسات التي انشئ قد انشئت في
وقت طويل مضى وهذه
المؤسسات
ليست لها هذه التجربه
فهناك النظام
يسمح باجوبه السريعه
الاشخاص الذين
اضاعوا بيوتهم وحياتهم
واراضيهم هم يريدون ان هذا الانصاف حاليا
وان لقي كل الضوء على الواقع وعلى الحقيقه
لدينا امثله محدده بهذا الشان نحن
نتحدث عن السجناء الحرب نحن ايضا نعمل على
هذا الاساس
نواد
ان نعرف كيف
الجنود رجالا ونساء كيف
يدافعون كيف يكافحون كيف يناضلين نحن
ان نفهم ما يحسن
فنحن
علينا
ان نعمل حتى
يمكننا ان نقدم الدعم
لجنودنا رجال والنساء في هذه السنه
نحن
تحدث عن ما حصل كان هناك
كان هناك الكثير من المشاكل فنحن
كان لدينا تبادل
الجنود وكذلك كانت
هناك ايضا سجناء سياسيين
واستطعنا ان نرجعهم ونتبادل مع
روسيا وهذا شيء مهم ايضا
والا سي دي ايضا تقوم بدور هام ايضا
ونحن نعمل مع هذه المنظمات
ونعمل ايضا
[موسيقى]
الكثير من الجوانب هذه الامور معقده
فلقد استمعنا الى الكثير من الاجوبه بهذا
الصدد ولقد
تعبت من يقول هذه ليست ولاياتنا ليس دورنا
ليس هذا دور المنظمات الدوليه لكن في نفس
الوقت فان الامم المتحده
والسيدس اشكره شكرا جزيلا على ما فعله نحن
نريد ان نعمل مع السيد
لقد تحدثت معه بهذا الشان
وتعنى ان نخلق هذا
الممر
بفضله فاننا
استطعنا اذن ان نتحدث عن هذه المواضيع لكن
اوكرانيا ومنشاتها ومؤسساتها والاتحاد
الاوروبي واوروبا والقاره كلها
والمؤسسات الدوليه عليها علينا ان نعرف
كيف يمكننا ان
نغيرها فنحن بحاجه الى
تحت
سياسيه
للانتصار في اطار هذه الحرب
مسائكم سعيد
بان
توفر الاسلحه اللي روسيا
انا لا اعرف كيف يمكننا ان نغير
شيء بهذا السدده انا اعتقد بان الصين قد
اعرببت عن بعض الافكار بشان خطه السلام
وانا اعتقد بان الصين بدات تتحدث عن
اوكرانيا
وتقول
ولكن
بعد الادعاءات ماذا سيحصل
نحن
بالافعل ما هو مهم هي الخطوات
تجاهها الى
النتائج التي نحن بحاجه اليها نحن نتحدث
عن او الصين تتحدث بعض الاشياء
انا اعتقد بان هناك احترام السياده
والسلامه الاراضي لكن لم يتم اشاره الى
ايه اراضي لو تحدثنا عن سلامه اراضينا نعم
لسلامه النوويه نعم انا اتفق مع ذلك وهذا
سيخدم مصلحه العالم هناك بعض الاشياء
هي مفهومه بالنسبه لي هناك بعض الافكار
التي لن اتفق معها والعالم لا يتفق معها
لكن بالاحرى هناك شيء يحصل
وحسب رايي هو انه
اذا كانت هناك افكار تجاهها السلام وان
يسير ذلك في اتجاه احترام القانون الدولي
وكذلك سلامه الاراضي
والاحترام الجوانب الامنيه اعتقد بان هذا
شيء جيد وان نعمل بشان هذا الموضوع لماذا
لا
انها مهمتنا هي ان
نتوحد
ونعزل اي طرف هذه هي مهمه الاساسيه
اذربيجان
متقدمه
من قبل بعض الدول الاخرى
وقد قدمنا لكم المساعده في السنه الماضيه
ما هي الاصلاحات التي تفكرنا فيها بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا بعد النصر ما هي الخطوات التي
ستتخذونها على المستوى السياساتي الوطنيه
والسياسات الاجنبيه
هل يمكننا اخذ صوره معك نعم
اياك يا موجو اياك يا موجو
كيف يمكنني ان اقيمه
الدعم الدعم
والجواب على سؤالكم اود القول بان حسب
رايي لو ان الصحفيين
السؤال باللغه الاوكرانيه
فهذا قرار اتخذ ما بين روسيا
[موسيقى]
اذا اوكرانيا نحن واود ان اشكركم على ذلك
ان اشكركم على مختلف انواع الدعم الذي
قدمتموه لاوكرانيا ورئيسكم احترم السياده
بلدنا وهذا شيء مهم بالنسبه لنا فلقد
احترم ايضا سلامه اراضي اوكرانيا وان رايه
هو راي جيد
للغايه وشكرا لكم
بانكم ستحققون اهدافكم
وان تجعلوا روسيا ستنسحب من اوكرانيا
وقلتم بانكم ستحققون ذلك
كان هناك دعم طبيعه المتحده
اننا نعرف بعضنا الاباد مع الجنرال وانا
شخصيا
ولدينا وهناك القاده الذين قدموا لنا
الدعم وكذلك
القوات العسكريه
وبالتالي
فان الامور مرتبطه بالدعم دوما وابدا
وهكذا
كان يريد بالفعل ان
من انسحابي العدو من بلدنا واعتقد بانه
بالتاكيد علينا ان نفعل ذلك
ويجب ان نتبع هذا النهجه فيما يتعلق
بالدعم
الجمعيه العملي للامم المتحده وكذلك
الولايات المتحده
حصلنا على مساعدات من الرئيس بايدن وكذلك
وحصلنا على الاسلحه ودعم المجتمع الامريكي
لقد لاحظت ذلك الاشخاص كانوا
يرفعون علمنا وارى بان هذا
الدعم الولايات المتحده هو قويه
فالامر من جهه اخرى يتعلق
بمساعده الماليه وكذلك العسكريه
لكن هناك ايمان راسخ في النصر والرئيس
بايدن كان موجود معنا واكد على هذا الامر
هل تعتقد بان او كان يمكنها ان تنتصر في
ساحه المعركه
هل سيكون عليك ان تتفاوض وان يكون هناك
ربما تنازلات
وسؤال ثاني
تقريبا عشرين من اعضاء النيتو قد
قوي
قدراتهم الدفاعيه بعد غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا
في هذه السنه
هل اذا هل يمكنكم ان تجيبوا على هذا
السؤال شكرا على هذا السؤال
اذا نسيت شيء رجاء ان تذكرينني اذا لم اجب
على كل هذه الاسئله
اعتقد بانهم هل هذا الجانب مهم جدا
لان هناك بلدان بالفعل في النيتو
الذين
من انظمتهم الدفاعيه
وميزانيتهم
وهذا سؤال
معقد وساعطيكم جواب معقد اي كيف يمكننا ان
نعيد الاصلاح ادخال الاصلاحات بالنسبه
للامن على المساواه العالمي فيجب ان نزيد
من ميزانيه مخصصه للجيش
[تصفيق]
بدانا نفكر في النيتو ونحن نفهم
باننا بحاجه الى
اشياء اكثر نحن بحاجه الى ذخائر ونحن
بحاجه الى منظومات دفاع حتى في الفضاء
وكذلك
الطائرات المسيره والكثير من التكنولوجيات
نحن نرى يجري
فهناك من يتحدث بانه يجب الزياده من
النفقات وكذلك التكاليف لكن اعتقد بان
ادخال الاصلاحات
على انظمه الامنيه هو شيء مهم لاننا
جميعنا
لاحظنا وشاهدنا ما وقع ونعرف يمكننا ان
نتوقعه من الاتحاد الروسي
ونحن
نقترب من
الحلول التوفيقيه
والجميع يعلم
الجميع يريدوا الحصول على الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
علاقات تجاريه مع روسيا بل بالعكس كانت
هناك عقوبات
ونحن
نعرف
بانهم
يتصرفون على النحو الذين يريدونه
ان نتركهم يفعلون ما يريدون ان يفقدوا اي
شيء على بلد او اخر
فان شخص واحد في روسيا علينا ان نفهم نحن
بحاجه الى الاستقلال ليس على الاوراق لاح
[موسيقى]
ما يفعلونه
في اوكرانيا
انظروا الى ما يحصل
فنحن
اعود الى سؤالك الاول
بعدما شاهدناه اي القتل والتعذيب وما يجري
كل يوم لاحظنا ذلك جميعا نحن
[موسيقى]
بالفعل
لا نخفي ما نفعله
والامر بالنسبه
للسكان
السكان الذين ليس لهم
اسلحه
هل نحن في اوكرانيا يمكننا ان نبقى مكتوب
في الايدي وان نجلس حول طاوله المفاوضات
نحن
لدي جواب علينا ان نبتدا من البدايه
فعلتموه في
عليكم ان تحترموا حقنا في ان نعيش في على
اراضينا
وان يقف القصف وان يتوقف القتل
للمدنيين
مهاجمه كل منشاتنا وكذلك قصف المدن والقرى
وقتل الكلاب والقطط والحيوانات
واحراق
كل الغابات يجب ان يتوقف كل ذلك وبعد ذلك
يمكننا ان نقول لكم كيف يمكننا ان نتصرف
من الناحيه الدبلوماسيه
اود ان اعود الى الموضوع الاول
وهذا هو الوقت لان نسخ لسا الدروس وسؤالي
هو كما يلي هل بامكانك ان تقول لنا
نحن
ما هي الاخطاء التي ارتكبتموها ربما وخلال
كانت هناك تعهدات
وهل هناك من كان بموضع خيبه امل بالنسبه
لكم بالنسبه لخيبه الى امل اود ان اقول
لكم بانني نسيت بدايه سؤالكم فكان لدي عمل
مكتب اليوم من
كل اولئك الذين غادروا اكياس 24 من فبراير
والذين غادروا المدن والقرى اولئك الذين
دون ان يكافحه ويناظلوا هؤلاء الاشخاص
كانوا موضع
اذن
شعره بشانهم بخيبه امل
اعمل ليلى نهار وانا
اعمل
ولو ان البعد لا يريدون ان ابقى على قيد
الحياه انا انا واثق بانني قد ارتكبت
اخطاء بالافاعي هناك لكن ما هو مهم هو
انني رئيس لم ارتكب اخطاء كبيره
ويمكنني ان ادافع عن الدستور وعن بلدي فلو
ارتكبت بعض الاخطاء الكبيره لكن قد اضعنا
بلدنا لكن لحسن الحظ لم ارتكب هذه الاخطاء
الكبيره
في بعض الفترات من الحرب
لقد شاهدنا
الشر الذي كان منتشره في بعض المناطق
سؤال فقط لو سمحتم
المؤتمر القمه في اليابان الذي سينعقد
لمجموعه السبع
وهل تشاركون في هذه القمه
وبالتالي ما هو دور اليابان في اطار
مجموعه السابع
للتعجيل من تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا
هذا سؤال جيد
بالفعلنا بالدعم الكامل من مجموعه السابعه
احيانا انسى الاسئله لان هناك الكثير من
الافكار وكذلك المهام
الاربعين دقيقه قبل الاجتماعين كانت لدي
مناقشه مع مجموعه السابع وان اوكرانيا
توجهت بدعوه
للمشاركه وبعد ذلك كانت لدينا بعض
المعلومات فيما يتعلق بتقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا وكذلك حزم حزن الحزم التي
تقدمها مجموعه سبعه وهناك دعم من اليابان
وانني
انني ممتنه
لرئيسه وزراء
هو يتحدث بوضوح وخلال هذه الحرب فهمته
قيمه الاشخاص مثل
وانني فهمت كل الدعم
والدعم المالي الذي
سيقدمه
رئيس وزرائكم لا تتذكر التفاصيل بدقه
لكنني على يقين باننا سنحظى بهذا الدعم
ولقد تواصلت ايضا من مجموعه السبع
رساله رئيس وزراء اليابان وجهاليه دعوه من
خلال القنوات
الدبلوماسيه وانا
لقد وجهت ان شخصيا دعوه لرئيس وزراء
رائيكم
ليزورنا في اوكرانيا
وهو
الضيف الذي ننتظره ونتوقع هنا
واليابان
قدموا دعم كبير لاوكرانيا
تعرفون
الدور الذي اطلعت به ايطاليا ايضا
من
خلال
اليابان
واعتقد بانه
في مرحله لاحقه سنتحدث بتفاصيل عن هذا
الدور هذا الدور الهام وهذا دور قوي
وايجابي
وشكرا لكم على ذلك
منذ سنه
كنت الشخص المطلوب اكثر في العالم
وانت اليوم معنا
انت تشعر بامان اليوم هل بوتين لا يستهدفك
بنفس الدرجه اليوم
حسب رايه
فيما يتعلق بهذا الامر بالنسبه لبوتين لست
لست ادري هذا
مميزه ماذا افعل ان دوره هو رئيس انا قائد
لبلدي
ولم افكر قطه
بشان اضعفي الدعم
فوحده
العالم هو الدوره الرئيسي الذي يجب ان
اطلع به هل فعلت ذلك بطريقه جيده ام لا هل
افعل ذلك لوحده لكن في البدايه عشنا فترات
صعبه للغايه
وكانت هناك حوارات
اذا صعبه مع الاتراك الرسميه وغير الرسميه
وبعد ذلك
كان كان
جميع رات
ولا حضر
ما حصل وما يحصل
نحن النوع
كافحنا من اجل حياتنا
وبعد ذلك اصبحت الامور
معقده لكننا
بدلنا كل الجهود فكل
مواطن الا
وعامل وهناك
لكن من جهه اخرى كانت هناك مشاكل مشاكل
مرتبطه بهذه الازمه
والاشخاص
لديهم مشاكلهم الخاصه ولكن العلم قدم
الدعم
لاوكرانيا
فنحن كنا بحاجه الى اموال
وكان من المهم ان نقول للجميع بان هذه
الحرب ليست حربنا وحدنا بل هي تخص الجميع
وروسيا تخلق هذه الازمه لاضعاف اوكرانيا
ولتدمير اوكرانيا
مره اخرى فكرت بان اوكرانيا لن تصمد لكننا
صمدنا وعملنا عملنا على كل المستويات على
مستويات كل الوزارات ك
نريد ان نفعل ذلك
وان ندافع عن انفسنا وهذه الفترات كانت
مهمه وهناك ايضا فتره حيث انه يكون عليكم
ان تقدمه شكرا للعالم
وانه لم يتخلى عنكم
وهذا
شيء مهم للغايه ان
نتقدم بالشكر ونعترف بالجميل
وهناك في بعض البلدان تحديات اخرى وانا
اقدم لهذه البلدان الدام وهذا شيء عادي
لان البلدان فعلت الكثير بالنسبه لنا
والمانيا فعلت الكثير من الناحيه الاماليه
ومن مختلف
المساله مختلف مستويات الكثير من البلدان
من الاتحاد الاوروبي قدمت لنا المساعده
وانني
افتح صفحه جديده
لاوكرانيا بالنسبه لكل الامكانيات
المتاحه
دفاعنا يحتاج الى الاسلحه
العسكريه وعلي ان اتحدث عن هذا الموضوع مع
الجميع وشكرا لكم شكرا لكم جميعا
انك تريد ان تلحق
الفشل بروسيا هل تعتبرون ان هذا شيء
سيتحقق
وبالنسبه لكم
ما هي
الاعتصارات التي حققتموها والتي انتم
تقرون بشانها منذ بدايه الحرب وشكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
البلدان بدات الحديث
سيحصل بعد
النقاه لكن حسب المعلومات
ماذا سيحصل بعد اقول ماذا سيحصل بعد اذن
ان نقضي على او ان
تفشل
الروسيه انا احدى بالدعم وانا اعلم
بالنسبه لنا بان اغلبيه البلدان
باحراف اوروبا تؤمن بان اوكرانيا ستنتصر
وهذا يعني بان هذا سيلحق فشلا
بالموسكو
هو ما هو مهم
سيحصل بعد ذلك بالنسبه لروسيا نعم في
الواقع هذا لا يهمني انا اعتقد بان روسيا
لها لها هي لها بلدها
ونحن علينا ان نفكر في بلدنا
فاذا لو كانوا فاننا
نحن
لو لم تتصرف روسيا على هذا القبيل لما كنا
نجد انفسنا في هذه المرحله وفي هذا الوضع
وبطبيعه الحال فان روسيا بلد غني لكن نحن
نعتقد بانه يجب ان نفكر في هذا الامر
علينا
ان نفكر
علينا ان نفكر في انفسنا فعلينا ان نبقى
على قيد الحياه علينا ان
لقد تجاوزنا الجائحه الكوفيد
وكل البلدان كافحه الكوفيد لكن كل بلد الا
ويفكر فيما يمكنه ان يفعله ضد
[موسيقى]
عدوان فانا لا افكر في هذه
المرحله
انا لا اقول بان بعض القدر سكبوا اخطاء
لكن كل فرض الا وله وجهه لكن حسب رايي
فانه فان هناك عقوبات اليوم بالنسبه
للمصاريف وكذلك
بانخ وكذلك
الاقليه الحاكمه التي لحقت بها ايضا
عقوبات كل هؤلاء الاغنياء ليسوا سعداء
بشان ما يجري لكن
فهم فهم يبقوا في الخارج لكن اليوم هؤلاء
الاشخاص ليس لهم كل هذا
لديه بقي في روسيا
فنحن
نعتبر
بانه ما فعلناه كان جيد اننا بالفعل
الحقنا عقوبات
هل الاغنياء تركوا رؤوس اموالهم في بلدهم
فنحن
تواصلنا بالكثير من المعلومات بهذا الصدد
ولكن لو ان
قاده الروسيين اصبحوا منعازلين
كان عليهم ان يفكروا في هذا
مسبق ساعتقد بانه ستكون لهم سياسه جديده
ويرغبون انذاك بان يجلسوا حول الطاوله
الاوكرانيه
منذ سنه مضت كنا جميعا شعرنا بسدمه
بالنسبه
لهذه الحرب وطلبنا من شركائنا بان يوفقوا
لنا الطائرات وان تكون هناك منطقه خاليه
من الطيران
وانتظرنا
لكن
ستصل الى اوكرانيا وبالنسبه للطائرات
الحربيه
رئيس بايدن قال بانه سوف لن يوفر اف 16
لاوكرانيا وسمعنا الى بيانات من قبل
وزرائنا
ان هناك حوار وان القرار سيكون لصالح
اوكرانيا هلا بامكانكم ان تشرحوا لنا ما
يجري
ربما طائرات اخرى مثل الاف 22
الجواب بالنسبه لهذا السؤال فيما يتعلق
بالاسلحه نعم من البدايه كانت الامور على
هذا المنوال مختلف الاسلحه من البلدان
الغربيه
وحسب معايير النيتو لم تكن لدينا هذه
الاسلحه وبكل صراحه اقول باننا
بدانا العمل بهذا الشان
كانت الشيء كانت صفحه جديده في اطار هذه
الحرب
فنحن اذا كنا كنا نريد
ونحتاج الى هذه الاسلحه
كنت ارغب في مركبات لحمايه
السكان كنت اريد ايضا الدبابات
ومختلف
على مختلف الاسلحه لكن نعتبر بان العنصر
الاساسي هو اننا
على انه بامكاننا ان نكافح وان ان نناضل
بغمايه اراضينا وانه كان من
المهم
[موسيقى]
لا تبقى الاكييف وخيرسون تحت الاحتلال
ودون هذه
الاسلحه لم يكن بامكاننا ان نفلح
اوكرانيا لم تفكر قط
ستحصل على منظومات لكن فتحنا هذه الصفحه
اليوم ولقد حضينا بمساعدات بهذا الصدد
الكثير من البلدان قدمت لنا الدعم
ولحسن الطالع
حصلنا على هذه المساعدات لكن كما قلت مع
الاسف هناك الكثير من الاشخاص الذين لقوا
حتفهم
قبل الحصول على هذه
الاسلحه
وبالتالي فنحن بحاجه بسرعه الى مثلا
طائرات مسيره او نحن
[موسيقى]
بحاجه الى بعض التكنولوجيات التي تخص
البحر هناك الكثير من الاشياء التي نحتاج
اليها
لحمايه
بنانا التحتيه
لحمايه المدنيين كان لدي اجتماع مع رئيس
الوزراء المملكه المتحده
واجاب على بعض الاسئله فلو حصلنا على
طائرات ذات نوعيه كبيره سنتمكن بان يكون
هناك تدريب مع بريطانيا كان لدي اجتماع مع
رئيس وزراء بولندا ونحن
نفكر في امكانيه تدريب الطيارين اف 16
ولدينا مفاوضات ايضا
بهذا
الشان لا اريد ان اشير الى
سنحصل عليه لكن من المؤكد اننا سنتوصل
بالمساعده من حيث الطائرات الحربيه وكذلك
التدريب نحن
نحتاج الى ذلك بسرعه لكن الامور معقده
سؤال قصير تحدثت عن اقتراح السلامه للصين
لكنك لم تشير ابدا الى انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من اوكرانيا نظرا
لوجهه نظر البلمانيين هذا يعني بان الخطه
السلام
الصينيه
لن
تصل الى نتيجه
ولا تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
يعني
اذا مشاهدينا كنا نغطي وقائع المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي يعقده الرئيس الاوكراني
لاوكرانيا تحدث الى مجموعه من الصحفيين
الذين طرحوا عليه اسئله عده حول مستقبل
هذه الحرب امكانيات اوكرانيا الدعم
الاوروبي الموقف الروسي موقف اوكرانيا وكل
ذلك